I can't wait forever another patient too
many things to do here comfy like a
sweater
but when the Sun comes out I won't be
needing you
[Music]
you smile conceals a secret and it's a
sickly sweet that I can't see the point
of taking deeper and through wassup
inside it's just so beautiful
[Music]
your eyes making me feel dizzy when you
quiz me on my childhood hairdo feet I'll
share with you if you kindly cut me like
[Music]
so compute rate on me but instead I
enjoy this view that tae-soo shallowly
[Music]
waiting's
what you disagree would you've only seen
them right here's where we both and to
afraid
[Music]
[Music]
but the past I can't see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm afraid to say the words
[Music]
I'm expected to first
[Music]
[Music]
this is just the story of a girl who
thought her heart
she needed to forget she needed a fresh
start
be careful what you say cuz she no
longer feels the same I can arise stains
right now
[Music]
sort of far i watch to regain the time
she lost when dates but like seconds
since both your pats crust sorted for us
whether keeping out this cold weather
buddy he keeps her about it
[Music]
she likes to think she's clever
sorry for our nickels are your worth for
yourself a cold
[Music]
I'm so lucky to regain her dignity
[Music]
this is just the story of a girl who
sold her house now she's forgotten she's
got a fresh start
[Music]
actually she owns yes
I
[Music]
is not was with it's worth the way she's
forgotten she's gone
[Music]
I remember when I first I left some to
my friend she's like that's pretty cute
was like yeah she dies
no she well it's up to you hi how are
you
oh my god what a freaking day it's been
I'm so glad to end of the day happy
Thursday
nearly Friday nearly my birthday and
sorry for confusing everyone I put up a
post about these live students and I got
so many nice birthday messages which I
need to reply to and then I was just
like oh crap I've rolled eggs my
birthday today doesn't matter
it basically is I'm gonna say hi to who
I can see here so hey Samuel Hey drained
or hazel Milanovic
entrance hey URL hello Internet hey Tom
so I think I think I saw Amy here as
well so it's it's down to Tom and Amy
that we can say thank you so thank you
hey Jamie I know it's the temperatures
like I like it I like it it's different
to the live one like I want it to be
nice and slow but when it's just me and
you clarity I feel like I need to speed
everything out because I feel like it's
really boring if I could slowly just me
and you can lady yeah shut up no kiss
how I talk to myself when I'm I know I
guess no one's even here hey Montez I'm
half working today
oh we doing a um are you still working
on something tea always takes so long
to cool down hey DJ guru here weird
noodles oh why didn't I put that behind
there thanks Audrey whoa I and you real
for following let me just put my alert
box in front of my face so you guys can
actually see cuz that would be a good a
good idea okay so for those of you who
might not be too sure what's happening I
have decided to do three live students
for my birthday this is just gonna be a
very short one just a heads up it's kind
of falling because I am going to do one
tomorrow and the next day Jesus Christ
come on daddy I'm gonna do one tomorrow
and Saturday so you can find out all the
details
I think it's an yeah it's in the
description down below so you can find
out the details down there I saw it it's
also on Instagram and Twitter but the
details for you now right now
I'm gonna open up your community present
which I'll talk more about that later
cuz I didn't even know that was gonna
happen
this livestream wasn't gonna happen I'm
very confused very excited feel kind of
overwhelmed we'll get there later and
then tomorrow I'm gonna paying debt by
daylight with my friends really nice I'm
saying with Tom and Amy who are in the
chat and a couple other people as well
so that'll be really nice that'll be at
7 o'clock BST time same as this so you
can catch us then tomorrow and that
would be a longer one and then um and
then on Saturday morning Amy and I wait
Amy we need to practice before it
happens
we're gonna do a morning breakfast show
live for you all
really excited because I've got an idea
and I'm gonna try and do it through
Animal Crossing but also live streaming
I like swallowed and spoke at the same
time but also livestream it so yeah you
should be able to see Amy and I in
Animal Crossing doing a morning show for
you and I will be sending out a dirty
code so if any of you guys play Animal
Crossing you can come to my Island and
run around in the background at the live
stream how fun would that be
I've got I've got a little set up now
I'm really excited this is a like
musical instruments so if anyone finds
what the podcast is happening or podcast
that the live stream is happening they
can make a run behind us and they can
play with little musical instruments
that I've put in the background so
anyway that will be on Saturday morning
but back to today oh yes sassy morning
that's 10:30 a.m.
BST time thank you for subscribing
positively heizo but yeah that just what
thank you for subscribing so today I'm
gonna be opening your community present
and yeah I guess just having a little
chat before I go honestly didn't expect
anything and I know that Tom and Amy are
behind it and a few people in discord as
well so yeah I guess I'll go and guess
it
[Music]
[Music]
I think it was from ki pigeon
funky pigeon tom tom can tell me I think
it's monkey pigeon cuz I got one full
moon pick and one some funky funky
pigeon but I think the moon pig one is
from my mum so uh yes
oh yeah if anyone's wondering about time
difference like delay and stuff from the
stream to you guys twitch is shorter
delay apparently so if it's annoying you
maybe switch platform I'm streaming on
both so you can try it both oh here it
is yeah okay okay so do what's behind
the curtain that's my clothes this is a
makeshift wardrobe see so um yeah I
guess card first first of all I thank
you so I honestly wasn't expecting I
wasn't really expecting anything
especially spent rafting quarantine you
know and I have been I've been really
spoil actually by my friends and my mom
even sending me some stuff which is nice
thank you
we all scrape together this card I hope
you like it
look at it it's you guys scraping your
bums on the floor I'm like I don't know
the logistics of this so I don't know
you know if you guys all chose all of
this together or you just kind of put it
into Tom or Amy's hands and they chose
but let's play funny
happy birthday Yasmin wait
happy Oh Montez had the great idea to
raise some money to get you your breath
three friends oh man toss Jesus Christ
thank you oh thank you guys so here we
are
see you at the birthday stream hi happy
birthday lots of love from the YAG my
next community Zalman Arabic peace Teddy
if 1-6
Nicki Amy Tom and mantas thank you so
much that means a lot
that's so cute oh my god and now I don't
know why I'm nervous this is like I
really wasn't expecting anything thank
you so much the cob does smell fresh I
hope let's see
please Cece why do I want to call you
species act Sikh religion running Jen
I mean yeah yeah oh I see why you said
that now right
I did I was on the phone to Amy and I
was like oh it's coming and done and she
was like don't open there my god it's
lit she just held on by the tiniest
little piece of tape oh okay maybe it
wasn't actually it wasn't my love I feel
like I'm not allowed to open it of its
release Isis oh did you get this did you
get this before I was gonna buy it did
you actually get it oh my god did you
actually get it okay wait context this
is a capture card oh my god we can use
this we can use today crossing guys are
we just gonna stream I was gonna string
the switch I was gonna stream the switch
screen through my bloody phone oh oh
this makes me so happy because I was
actually gonna buy a capture card like
did you did you guys did you do this
wait cuz I swear I had this on my floor
unopened and I went to go and buy the
capture card and I had it in like Amazon
basket and I was effing and aming about
whether I should buy it or not and then
I was just like screw it I'm gonna buy
it and by the time I
it was all gone they were all sold out
and I was like I shouldn't face it oh my
gosh I think it was if when I said he
they're like oh you worried us so I
think you did yeah you had already
gotten me the CAPTCHA card that I was
going to buy myself literally like last
week or something I'm great minds think
alike we both knew that I needed one
thank you so much
honestly it means so much and I am going
to use this through the streams don't
you worry I'll get some good use of it
Amy
I even firmed up Amy and I was like I
was gonna buy a capture card today but
they'd all ran out I was like oh wait
it's probably probably a waste of my
money anyway and she was like yeah
probably a good need and buy it thank
you for following GE they're TDH oh my
gosh Saturday it's going to be amazing
I'm so glad that you got me this because
I've been spending hours making animal
crossing as good as I can be for you
guys on Saturday and now you're gonna
see it in very good quality there's lots
of people buying them up because of
animal crossing yeah exactly Tom whose
idea was this
how did you guys know how do you know me
so well who is this I don't I can't even
open it
a lot of people are going up stretch now
because of the delay or like yeah use
the camera to record it yeah I remember
cuz we were talking about it in discord
I was like guys should I buy a capture
card you guys are so sneaky
I didn't literally I didn't I didn't
know what this was I actually had no no
clue what this could be
thank you for the follow cold cold cold
dog
cold dog no seven number seven you
mentioned it a few times on the stream
that you wanted to buy but you couldn't
you guys listen I won't get that one day
this is why I was saying you should open
it today because it will take a while to
set up that's a very good point on thank
you and the good thing about this is is
that this is the exact one exact ones
that I was going to buy so I've already
watched tutorial videos on how some
music is apparently in all the reviews
that I saw they were like just get the
elgato it works so good and you might as
well spend a bit of extra money on an
anklet
I'll get it oh my god I feel like I'm
such I'm such a lucky girl
oh it comes with a sticker guys
so yeah I guess thanks to you guys the
stream on Saturday it's going to be even
better what you got I got a capture card
and word so you're prepared for your
gift already exactly yeah
we were definitely aligned falcata can't
wait I cannot wait I had them I have my
friend come to my Island yesterday just
so we could test out because we're gonna
be using like dildo codes and stuff but
I didn't want the stream to be disrupted
by people coming to my Islands I'm gonna
close the gate when everyone gets there
we looked around I've got a couple of
friends with an L guess and we figured
it would be best you got one with a good
foundation of textbook that's very true
Tommy yeah that's another reason why
because um I was looking at the
tutorials and they were saying that al
gasser just comes with like everything
straight on the box so it's the most
simple capture card and I was like there
and also it's um I think it works for
both PC and Mac - not that I probably
will use use it in my Mac but you know
it's good to know
not taking credit no way this could have
been done without everyone you chipped
in thank you so much I really I don't
know what to say yeah
apart from this yeah this is gonna be
good front for all of us and I wasn't I
wasn't expecting it I'm so happy
thank you so much and mantis was the
mastermind of Harley
I don't know why with the elgato logo
looks a bit like the Lincoln Park
loading no go do something else as well
but I can't think what it is steam maybe
the headphones logo you've got good
friends yeah I do I have loads of nice
people in my life and I'm actually
really lucky on everyone's like mantises
MVP mantises MVP MVP MVP thank you I had
I had like a rowing intense stay or
waxes this is a nice little surprise
afterwards Oh Amy
fancy you finally following me after all
this time and you call yourself up
friends well now what I want to play
with it now well like I said this is
gonna be a short stream I actually do
have things to get on with tonight and
then obviously tomorrow is gonna be the
main stream and then I'm gonna have to
figure out how I can I think I think I
know I have to watch the tutorials put
it on my switch right here it's so
tempting with it just having right here
cuz I've work here my dad school and I'm
just like oh I could just no nope nope
nope no animal crossing
yes now I gotta go mess with my new tech
that's very true
well how about I sing a song to you
before I leave cuz I don't want to just
for Sunday so we're just like puffing on
here for half an hour to open something
you guys got me I can sing you guys a
song but what do you want to hear what
would you like um actually no last time
I did that you were asking for crazy
things and I was like I wish I'd what
they think that I'm Way more
following is on Twitch instead of
YouTube yeah yeah oh yeah don't worry
there's a YouTube and twitch I'm like
streaming to birth things and don't
worry that I wouldn't say anything like
like that to anyone else other than Amy
it's just because Amy knows me very well
and I can be sassy to her because she's
always sassy to me you know friend sess
it's birthday thank you Michael
but it's tomorrow but it's tomorrow just
you know just just tomorrow but we have
something oh my god and actually I'm so
excited
Amy how the hell I was having such a bad
mood on the firm's house like Buble
capture card and then like it's not what
it's like sometimes it's like things
happen for a reason I think that song so
lame but how weird is that hope
coincidental is that if I had pressed by
now literally five minutes earlier I
would have bought it cuz I would have
bought the last one in stock on Amazon
but I waited because I was unsure and
then it was out of stock when I pressed
by now because it was in my basket so it
so weird
oh it's Katie
weird dude huh okay I should have
guessed really you shouldn't I
so I knew I know Katie from my hometown
as well so now I realize he really did
all this okay we sassy to you as well
Katie my heart skipped a beat when I
read the chat about you buying it
yeah I know I I think I even told Amy as
well I was like I told someone I was
like oh yeah man Taos said you know
don't don't like impulse buy or
something I was like yeah actually he's
got a point
maybe it wasn't impulse buy see what you
did there I see what you did there
I'm sorry I kicked the table hello
are you okay did you survive
sorry I'll pick you back up yeah you oh
okay let me just wipe off the dirt in
your face oh wait um everything is like
oh no everything's mess it up
wait where to put you I don't does I
want to put you anywhere like under
wards that makes sense right I'll put
you in get to see my beautiful pocket
Begay back on you're perching spots
I've started to use my phone now but I
still haven't figured out a good setup
for the webcam because it's just on like
a phone tripod and I just kind of
squeeze it in there you go
squeezed it in back up normally now are
you after Tom's leaving as I'm just like
staying around with the phone bye tom
thank you thank you thank you so much
already appreciate it okay a stupid
house fell over again stupid Alice
stupid house I don't even live in a
house if this flat fellow oh damn that
would be quite scary
white girls don't rap obviously you
haven't watched my latest music video
right burp at the very end of this phone
oh thanks Aaron thank you for the
birthday wishes but again it's tomorrow
but I will take them all now we just
give them to me I'll take the mom take
them home uh yeah so I was gonna sing to
you to say thank you how about just keep
it nice and easy and we just go back to
sweater I haven't seen his sweater in
ages
[Music]
I can't bring forever another patient
I've got to anything sits in your comfy
sweater when the Sun comes out I won't
be needing smile can't seals a secret
and it's a sickly sweet and I can't see
I've taken deeper service office that is
just so beautiful I don't wanna spoil
your so please don't leave that down oh
cool your eyes make me dizzy
[Music]
with me on my childhood I'll share with
you if you so tiny cup my that's I can't
see I can pry through the crap so for
dick bloom
I'm you straight on to me but instead I
enjoy this new that I so shallow
[Music]
I don't wanna throw out here soon
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
they go blast past
all right thank you for my briefly
present I love it I was not expecting
anything so it means a lot
it means a lot it means best room for
you on Saturday
so yeah cool cool cool thanks thanks
thanks okay oh don't forget
see you tomorrow same time well actually
7 p.m. so the same time at this started
BST British summer time where I'll be
playing dead by daylight with Amy Tom
and a couple other friends so you'll get
to meet them tomorrow as well I don't
think you've met the other friends
that'd be fun and yeah I have I think I
have amy's present to open so I'll
either open that one on Saturday or
tomorrow I'll ask her what she wants
could be quite fun to open it on the
little podcasting live streaming thing
that we do but yeah we'll see
yeah and then obviously Saturday 10:30
a.m. be there if you want to be don't if
you don't cool okay I'm I'm gonna go
have a lovely day or evening composers
I'm turning 30 40 slip in mind yeah of
course 40 40 I'm gonna say goodbye to I
can see in the chat so oh yeah and thank
you so much again - I'm just gonna say
from the card so - montage
- if 196 is da Milanovic - Nicki and P
steady as well
obviously tombe me thank you so much
Eliseo
hell yeah thank you thank you thank you
I appreciate this is too much I'm gonna
go now why you like I get very
overwhelmed
um I'll see you tomorrow same time
see you then and play some games have
some fun okay cool I'm by Montez by
drained or by some Lana Vic and f 1 9 6
by Nikki Gaurav by Eliseo and thank you
thank you so much again for your tip I
really appreciate that thank you and
goodbye
peace teddy goodbye Amy will secret
until the stream tomorrow
what secret what secret more secrets
I would probably know it okay the
present that Amy okay cool cool by Jamie
by Michael tannic by Jessie Xavier no
javi I'm sorry if I'm saying wrong sorry
say give this one by Rahul by scanners
by Katie witty doodles
I remember though because I think I
remember you telling me that your name
was really doodles by is there anyone
else by would by by Babur by bad bad bad
bad by I think that was everyone by Sun
you all if I haven't already by Bradley
bound I don't know why said like that I
think it's cuz I was gonna sleep brown
and then I realize it's not and by
Albert oh no don't worry I'll keep this
dream up it's a really is a very quick
stream so I'll keep it up it's cool
bye Melvin and goodbye to anyone that I
haven't seen bits in the chat I think
goodbye hey Kaylee as well and good bye
Miguel and yeah see you tomorrow and
good bye also to the people who want in
the jet and I just watching really
appreciate you being here
- so have a good evening
see you guys tomorrow and by URL okay I
like using a good camera yeah anyway
right bye